♪ ♪
>> Laura: SOAK UP IN HER
GREG ABBOTT OF TEXAS DEPLOYED
STATE LAW ENFORCEMENT AND BORDER
PATROL AS MIGRANTS FLED ACROSS
THE BORDER.
IN THE CRISIS IS DEEPENING FOR
REASONS YOU MAY NOT HAVE
SUSPECTED.
RAYMOND ARROYO JOINS US LIVE
FROM THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY AND
IT IS THUNDERING AND LIGHTNING
HERE, BUT WHAT ARE YOU SAYING
THERE?
>> LAURA, WE OFTEN HEAR THERE IS
A HUMAN CRISIS AT THE BORDER.
WHAT I HAVE FOUND OVER THE LAST
FEW DAYS IS THAT THAT CRISIS MAY
BE COORDINATED.
IT IS A COMBINATION OF BIDEN'S
BORDER POLICIES AND CRIMINAL
ELEMENTS AS WE DISCOVERED
EMBEDDED WITH THE MEMBERS OF
TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF SAFETY, THEY
ARE SPECIAL OPS DIVISION, WATCH.
>> STAND ON THE BANKS OF THE
RIO GRANDE IN ROME AND TEXAS ON
A WEEKEND NIGHT AND THERE IS A
PARTY LITERALLY ON THE RIVER.
LIEUTENANT CHRISTOPHER IS A
TEXAS RANGER.
>> YOU CAN SEE THE CARS, THE
CARS JUST DRIVING AROUND ON
PURPOSE.
AND ONCE IT KIND OF DIES DOWN,
THAT IS WHEN YOU START SEEING
THE CRIMINAL ACTIVITY TAKING
PLACE.
>> THE RIVER DISTRACTION RIFLES
THE WATER SHOW AT THE BELLAGIO
AND A CHANCE TO SCOPE OUT
QUIETER LOCATIONS UP AND DOWN
THE RIVER.
SPEAK WITH THE TRAFFIC
CONSTANTLY COMES THROUGH HERE.
>> WE DROVE TO A FAVORITE CARTEL
DROP POINT PATROLLED BY TEXAS
NATIONAL GUARD.
WE WAITED IN THE DARK UNTIL
1:00 A.M. WHEN THE CARTEL
STARTED MOVING MIGRANTS ACROSS
THE RIO GRANDE.
THEY CAME AND THEY CAME SOME
MORE.
YOU NOTICE THEY ARE TAGGED WITH
BANDS, WHICH IS OPERATING
PROCEDURE FOR THE CARTEL.
THEY LITERALLY TAGGED THESE
PEOPLE, AND NOT ONLY ARE THEY
CLIENTS OF THE CARTEL, BUT IN
SOME CASES, THEY HAVE TO WORK
OFF THEIR JOURNEY ONCE THEY ARE
IN AMERICA.
THERE IS NO DOUBT THEY WERE
BROUGHT HERE BY THE CARTELS, BUT
WHEN QUESTION, THEY WON'T SPEAK
AT ALL.
AFTER DROPPING OFF THESE
MIGRANTS, THE SMUGGLERS RETURNED
TO MEXICO.
THIS IS A BUSINESS.
AND IN MANY WAYS CAN A DECEPTION
FROM A DISTRACTION, HUMAN ONE.
UP THE ROAD THEY ARE MET BY
BORDER PATROL WHO NOW UNABLE TO
PATROL ARE FORCED TO REGISTER
AND TRANSPORT HUNDREDS OF
MIGRANTS.
DUE TO THE RELAXED BIDEN BORDER
POLICIES THE SURGE OF MIGRANTS
HAS INCREASED AND SO HAS THE
POWER OF THE UNSEEN CARTEL.
AND ONCE THEIR PROCESS BORDER
PATROL BRINGS MIGRANTS HERE TO
THE RESPITE CENTER IN McALLEN
IT IS ONE FAITH AFFILIATED
GROUPS THAT HELP THESE MIGRANTS
SETTLE INTO AMERICA AND HELP
THEM FIND THEIR DESTINATIONS AND
SEND THEM ON THEIR WAY.
>> IT IS A POEM FOR THE WHOLE
COUNTRY.
THEY PASSED THROUGH HERE BUT
THEY DON'T STAY HERE APPEAR THEY
COME TO MACCALLUM AND THEY ARE
TRANSPORTED OUT.
SO THEY PASSED THROUGH HERE AND
ARE GONE.
AFTER THAT, IT IS A PROBLEM FOR
THE WHOLE COUNTRY.
>> HE SEES THROUGH THE CARTEL'S
GAME.
>> SOMETIMES IT SEEMS WE ARE
PARTNERING UP WITH THE CARTEL.
IT IS NOT RIGHT.
IT DOESN'T SEEM RIGHT WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT HALF OF THE
POLICIES ARE CHANGED, WHATEVER
THEY ARE.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING RIGHT NOW IS
NOT OKAY.
>> LAURA, THE MAYOR'S RIGHT.
THE BIDEN POLICY AT THE BORDER
REALLY HAVE TURNED BORDER PATROL
INTO THE PARTNER OF THE CARTEL
AND A WILLING PARTNER.
THAT IS WHY GOVERNOR ABBOTT HAD
TO DISPATCH A THOUSAND OF HIS
OWN LAW ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE TO
RE-BOLSTER THOSE AND FILL IN THE
GAPS.
BY THE WAY, BORDER PATROL HAS
ARRESTED 180,000 MIGRANTS IN THE
MONTH OF MAY.
TOMORROW, WE WILL TELL YOU THE
REAL ACTIVITY OF THE CARTELS AND
WHAT THEY WERE DOING BEHIND THE
SCENES.
IT IS FRIGHTENING.
>> Laura: THIS IS SO -- IT'S
SO SHOCKING ON SO MANY LEVELS.
THE ADJUTANTS DON'T EVEN FLOW AT
THIS POINT, RAYMOND.
IT IS BOTH HEARTBREAKING,
INFURIATING, DISHEARTENING,
DISCONCERTING, OUTRAGEOUS.
AGAIN, THE ADJECTIVES DO NOT
CAPTURE IT IS A HUMAN TRAGEDY
AND ECONOMIC DISASTER.
IT HURTS OUR SCHOOLS, OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AND EVERYBODY
FEELS BAD WHERE THEY COME FROM A
COUNTRY WHERE THEY CAN'T GET A
JOB BUT THAT IS HALF OF THE
WORLD.
>> THEY ARE BEING ABUSED.
>> Laura: OF COURSE THEY ARE.
>> THEY ARE BEING SOLD A BILL OF
GOODS, GETTING PAID AND USED BY
THE CARTELS.
SOMETIMES IN THE TRADE BUT OTHER
TERMS USED FOR VARIOUS
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
>> Laura: OUR FOCUS, RAYMOND,
BUT OUR FOCUS HAS TO BE ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
OUR PRESIDENT IS SUPPOSED TO BE
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
INTEREST.
HE SCREWED IT UP OVER IN EUROPE
THE LAST FEW DAYS.
NOW ONGOING CRISIS AT THE BORDER
THAT AS WE HEARD LAST WEEK
DESCRIBED BY THE TEXAS GOVERNOR,
RAYMOND, IT IS PURPOSEFUL.
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY ARE DOING
AND FLED THE ZONE WITH NEW
PEOPLE.
THEY WANT NEW PEOPLE COMING IN N
THE COUNTRY FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS.
THAT IS WHAT THEY WANT AND THAT
IS WHAT THEY ARE GETTING.
2 MILLION PEOPLE WILL BE HERE BY
THE END OF THE YEAR.
>> THEY ARE EMPOWERING THE
CRIMINAL CARTELS.